hey guys it's a guarantee no Chuck Gary
Vaynerchuk calm and Dinah do all these
pretty fun actually you might notice we
just are about to tape a Wine Library TV
episode and we flipped the camera angle
which is absurd um and we've just
changed the game and actually that's
what I want to talk to you guys about
slightly today which is this reactionary
business see I think way too many people
obsess and spend a lot of time
especially entrepreneurs on what's gonna
happen in the future and really I don't
give a rat's ass about what's gonna
happen in three years I could care less
if Twitter is gonna make money or not
though I want to because Evan mismos
guys are awesome actually Ben said
something bad about New York so I gotta
think about that for a minute but um I'm
not worried about where Facebook is
going or what's gonna be the next
platform i know there was friendster
than myspace than facebook things are
always gonna evolve who's the best you
know I think people like sucks are gonna
be around forever i think you know i
really don't care habits mobile I really
don't care you know where people moving
which countries are in play China Europe
I really don't care what I care about is
when it happens to be the best person in
executing in the newest game that's
what's up guys I've never predicted a
damn thing have I seen it fairly early
on and used it launching Wine Library
com in 1997 launching a video blog in
early two thousand six sure but I didn't
invent it I definitely didn't think
about it way too many people obsessing
about where businesses going instead of
paying attention to the little things
that are actually happening already and
an executing at a very young age I don't
want to predict the birth I just want to
play with the baby when it's one years
old you get it reactionary business is
where it's at see you later